or jesus louisardo back on his home
mound in more ways than one of course
from parkland florida so a strikeout and
a walk to begin the night freddy freeman
having a big series having a big year
but what's new
this one to right field
and it's gonna get to the wall solaire's
on his way to third he's getting waved
around jazz has it here comes his throw
and it
[Applause]
to jazz to jackson and they get solaire
at home plate
sanchez good strong throw to jazz he's
gonna finish it off i thought this was a
bold send
solaire was a little bit behind as far
as timing coming around third base
as long as you had a clean catch and
nice job by alex jackson coming up
with the baseball a little bit of a
short hop
a huge play here in the first but no
matter who's out there you feel good
about your chances jeff with charlie
morton taking the ball for the braves
here were scoreless morton's one-two
pitch
and angular didn't get that boy that's
as sharp as charlie's been
at any time this year two strikeouts in
a scoreless first from miami alex
jackson brian de la cruz and jesus
luzardo here in the bottom of the third
inning
as morton blows him away that's four
strikeouts one away in the third inning
and a slow tapper dansby charges scoops
fires and got him by a step
and another one there and it's in the
hole at short dansby off balance throw
and freeman stretches out wow
all right here's freddy freeman top of
the fourth no score
and he smokes that one into right field
he might have another double that's
always a good plan freddy's on his way
to second sanchez digs it out in the
corner freddie's chugging they're going
to send him chism's throw to third is
going to be
late
freddie freeman deeks him and he's got
his first triple on lead off three base
hit and the braves are in business to
start the inning
an rbi chance for riley
and he smokes that one into center field
down for a hit in atlanta leads one
nothing riley's going after the first
pitch twice and he's hit it on the
button twice freddie freeman scores
another run and the braves strike first
it's one to nothing well another spot
where a fly ball gets you a run duvall
thinking about more than that here bases
loaded one in nobody out
hey missed inside boy that was close a
basis loaded walk atlanta leads two
nothing
here three balls two strikes
and another bases loaded walk it's just
like st louis three straight walks two
of them have come with the bases loaded
swanson will trot home and score
bases remain loaded charlie morton's
coming up and the braves lead by three
so stephen oaker jeff comes in on a
giant mess simple for him damage control
ozzy a fly ball to right
sanchez backs up
gets behind the ball makes the grab
darno is tagging the braves catcher on
his way to the plate to throw up the
line and ozzie does his job with his
84th rbi on a sacrifice fly
atlanta extends the lead it's four to
nothing
the pitch
and solaire swings through it and that
retires the side all in all by oakrid
pretty good job base is loaded nobody
out he allows one run the only base
runner was a walk to the pitcher for
charlie morton
and strike three chisholm flipped the
bat he thought he earned ball four he
shakes his head
and he better watch it or he might get
run
0-2 ground ball out to second ozzie a
few steps to his left he's gloving it
cleanly sends it over to freddie freeman
two down
that disappeared morton has six
strikeouts he's got a no-hitter through
four and he leads four nothing and
freddie freeman leads off again next
one ball one strike
and freddie on to the glove of aguilar
he's aboard again he's got the double
the triple the singles
this one up the middle and a diving stop
chisholm tried the glove flip nobody
home rojas picks up the loose ball and
riley's got to hit
genthers 2-2
swinging a fly ball hit well toward
right long run sanchez still going to
the track nice play freddy's going to
tag up and he's going to head to third
and atlanta's got him at first and third
with one out which you knew he would the
pitch
swinging a fly ball center that's well
hit warning track wall it's high off the
fence duvall just missed freeman scores
riley's gonna stop at third
man he you're right that you can see the
indention here in a minute on the wall
i don't even know if a foot and it was
gone chip
might have been just under he
stays inside it beautifully goes the
biggest part of the park
[Applause]
bottom five in miami braves up five
nothing
the marlins have their first hit a
single up the middle for
nissan diaz
let's see is hit by the pitch right
there
a lot going on there this one into right
field and it's going to drop for a base
hit
they will hold isan
strong throw from solaire and it's
smothered by darno a nice job to keep it
in front
one ball two strikes
broken bat roller to short swanson
albies and they will just get de la cruz
at second
esan diaz comes in to score
rbi ground out on the fielder's choice
for alfaro and it's now five to one
miggy into right field there's a base
hit
alex jackson will score
and it's now five to two
one more key hit nice job staying behind
the baseball and front leg
straightens out stays behind it drives a
fastball to right
freddy
needs the homer for the cycle
as this one's wack to center that ball
is deep that ball is at the wall that
ball is gone it's the cycle for freddie
freeman
[Applause]
have a night
[Applause]
wow
he's an mvp you know young kid falling
behind 2-0 realizing i can't throw that
pitch to the reigning mvp and freddie
just had enough to clear it wall scraper
as he hits for the cycle for the second
time a base for diaz who's at third for
de la cruz who's at second 2-2 pitch
anderson ground ball to third riley's
got it
over to first
a run comes in to score rbi ground out
and it's now 7-3
with one out runners of the corners
pitch on the way ground ball hot shot
that's a base in the left field ozzy
comes in to score
austin's got another rbi
it's a single to put freddy freeman down
at second base the braves have him
loaded
as darneau takes another basis loaded
walk boy the braves have that play down
don't they
that's the third one of those they've
earned in this game 18 bases loaded
walks in the season no 5 and 10 and
right now we have 15 this season
now we have 16.
3-1 pitch
and another basis loaded walk
three of them in the inning now that's
17 for the year
josh tomlin is on for the bottom of the
ninth inning first and third nobody out
de la cruz in the air out toward left
center field
it's going to be her ready to make the
play
sac fly for de la cruz
lined into center field there's the base
hit one run is in they will hold leon
and for jazz a couple of hits
late in the ball game tonight it's now
11-5
there's a ground ball base hit into left
field
jazz will come around throw from duvall
is not in time jazz tumbles his way home
and aguilar brings in two more
[Music]
got a lot going on there i think he
ripped his pants lost a chain tumbled
yard sale action
and will smith is going to come on not a
save situation but will didn't have many
tosses
sanchez with a drive out to right
and that's into the upper deck a two-run
shot for jesus sanchez
and the marlins are down by two
[Music]
into the upper deck in right field he
knew it off the back
will smith not too happy that sanchez
got jiggy with that one no there was
definitely some words yeah he walked out
and walked at him a little bit had a
few things to say
well this would be something so you
decided to trade me to the marlins did
you
and the o2
game over never in doubt braves win it
11-9
it was 11-9 and the marlins gave the
braves a scare in the bottom half
you